e aí galera que assistir meu canal tudo
bom vocês olha só quem aparece neste
canal em claro o dono dele volta e meia
tem que dar as caras que estão com esse
negócio aqui que eu e no japão o aaa a
descobrir que sei fazer imitações de
baleia cabelo e também é um aparelho
detector de quem vai dar um clique no
vídeo agora entendeu a click gostei aí
porque você foi detectado aqui e ao
final do vídeo desde os comentários que
foi você achou mais parecido porque nem
todos são paulo porque os imitadores são
espertos eles pegam a parte da música
que mais parece e colocam como se
soubesse cantar a música inteira gohan
unidos também cantam todas as cidades de
e já vamos lá né
ainda pego num galão
e tanto senai/al menéndez caninana mãe
ela pesa em mim é esse tal de nice ano
saiu
né eu sempre digo que não precisa saber
que está em inglês para cantar em inglês
como é o caso do alan jackson várias
técnicas observada com o tempo né
aprimorados que resulta na música
country de a um jec é a junção de uma
mobilete que faz aquele barulho assim ó
com esse movimento de língua que quem
faça euros havendo aqui só aparece aqui
ó lá um tipo gato salgado com carneiro
tem quando atacou o cargueiro está
puxando a clarificar se junta isso com a
mobilete nasce alan jackson
[Música]
pra mim ele lê lilian
a lello em unir o irão
minha casa
a ram wi fi
em maruja
olá lá no rio
o win são a dra
[Música]
são várias formas de cantar em inglês
sem saber que está em inglês já falei
não precisa saber que está gripada
inglês própria de xira mesmo eu tirei
como estudo para saber que você não
precisa bater o time inglês a partir de
agora você vai saber cantar em inglês
você nunca mais vai passar vergonha das
pessoas se está cantando essa música
também você tá na roça na parede rap
base tio é uma técnica muito fácil que
eu inventei sabe nesses momentos que eu
não tô aqui no fazendo bico pra vocês eu
to fazendo alguma coisa
esta técnica e inventei você vai pegar a
primeira frase da música e cantar muito
alto a segunda frase você vai cantar
pingas no meio da música você enfim o
nome de alguém que você conhece
ok primeira frase muito álbum impacto
entender passo está mesmo a segunda fase
bem baixinho pra confundir que a pessoa
não sabe inglês ela chegou infantil em
landim sakineh antes a pessoa tá perto
também não sabe inglês fala é em inglês
no meio da música o nome de alguém eu
boto meu amigo estava no meu casamento
francisquinho fica mais ou menos assim
pretensão é nokia
[Música]
o max é na capital
skin o carro agora está passando o sul
da capital do haiti está passando na sua
banda andré bateu agora eu só penso no
bailão da 101 2000
ai ai meu pai de pegar minha boneca
choque e ainda era boa e acabamos de
bater na bola ao player desgraça se não
me meto na desgraça na sua desgraça de
graça ao cavalo ligou e aí no xampu
você é louco por você dá dor de cabeça
maior e você tem que comigo nessa missão
é paranóico ricci eu não posso toda vez
que você quer sair da escola e deixar
minha vida é a morte que está falando
bobagem você morre torcedores possíveis
morgan a
[Música]
eu vou rifar meu coração por fazer leão
o bem dela quem terminar eu vou rifar
meu coração
o padre leão por amor carinho e bar às
vezes quer saber você vai bem sem mim
entenderem que querendo é prudência
pudesse iria me encontrar e dei eu já
tentei colocar mais pé no chão
entreguei para achar uma solução
só que essa solução pode ser bem melhor
pra mim do que pra você
se era isso que você queria uma noite
apenas ser banheiro e quer de mim
mamãe mamãe na internet não está
funcionando de novo a dizer
[Música]
eu não posso negar o feitiço que ela me
fez o time ta são vocês a questão que
vamos vencer fácil essa que a aap quem
gostei
exatamente a você mesmo clicando em
gostei da click gostei como o nome de
que você achou mais parecido ou se tem
amigos aqui é que o limite
obrigado por ter assistido vídeo até
aqui me aguarde muitas vezes mais esse
ano aqui no youtube porque você está
ligado que o negócio aqui é leve o
processo é barato louco pro tamo junto a
nós um beijão e hanói valeu